I call this dirty Artie's horse
graveyard I got dirty
we got magnet one magnet two magnet
three magnet for and and Steve like say
a few words to my horses last episode we
lost we lost a few more than a few more
hit a few oh good you're good you're all
right you're all right you're all right
that's my girl welcome back to dirty
Artie we are here at dirty our horse
graveyard we thought we'd kick things a
little more emotional you know
rest in peace maggot your beautiful
white braided tail will be missed but
we're kicking off this is now chapter
six happy Friday thank you all for
joining us we have we kind of realized
you know through some comments of the
last episode that we are we're not
getting anything done at all yeah we
even ended last episode saying well we
got a lot done and then I remember
thinking no we didn't get much done at
all we got we got a pair of chaps so I
took the liberty of at least knocking
off one thing that I have been wanting
to do forever so if you go to your
outfits Oh on the horse riding the horse
yeah and switch it to custom yeah
please work oh yeah we are good I was
about to freak out and yell okay try it
again
there it is
yeah pretty good right so that was a
comment last week said you should
probably at the trapper and sound denis
they said you should go with the
legendary bear jacket and i agreed and
it wasn't too hard to get just it was a
it was a bear pelt and a perfect bison
pelt so we knocked that off we're just
gonna we're just gonna kick it off
that's a good fit
murder who did I kill I think you were
next to a guy yep
horses next to someone so what else are
we gonna do in this episode Jake well
we're gonna find a canoe for reasons
that you'll find out yes that's that's
our closer today is finding a canoe and
uh and we've come up with a little game
- we've come up with a little game I
have in my hands a large coin it's
actually you know perfectly a red red
red dead redemption collector's edition
coin it's pretty big
and what we're gonna do is let me just
let me just compare this with this way
to a movie called no Cohn No Country for
Old Men
Harvey our bow dams here Bardem bar dam
his character if you know would flip a
coin and it would it would he would give
his victims as a chance to live or die
based on the outcome 50/50 of the coin
so we're gonna do the same thing with
people here we're gonna flip a coin and
decide their fate oh all right perfect
all right here it is first guy okay so
there's a there's a logo and there's a
bison on this coin which is what should
we do it so if it's if it's the Bison do
we kill bison kill bison kill Oh -
partner bison would you like to play a
game
[Music]
[Laughter]
I'll happily pull this trigger
okay sorry she said I felt this coin I
might just need to kill these guys
that's fair yes whoa dang damn damn you
nailed it
that was perfect we've been trying to do
that for a while do some looting mm-hmm
shuffle rides up to this camp at full
speed flip a coin dang that was pretty
funny oh my god you think that was
intentional I don't know that was like
hard to tell if it was scripted because
it almost remind me of the guy who gets
kicked by the horse you know
oh yeah hello let me get the window up
there I know you're in there Oh would
you like to play a game oh you like
bossing my friend this isn't no that's
fine take this one okay [ __ ] Steve Steve
- oh no dude let's get that Brit a white
braided tail I wanted that oh look he
loves it he's he loves his new tail oh
right yeah
take it try to get it inside oh my god
forget it oh yeah well well well
oh these are just little annoying
Raiders yeah just all right called you
an idiot no you guys get dynomite
you didn't see that coming did you like
sawed-off shotguns are good a good dirty
Rd weapon Oh kill Dan yeah it is it's
totally a good very well oh oh let's get
a new friends getting a pet
oh yeah gotcha gotcha we're probably
gonna need to kill this guy before we go
to roads probably we'll find a way to do
it
wait yeah we might kill Steve to the
wheel set ourselves up there we throw
him off something oh that's a good idea
yeah that's a pretty good hide I hope
you're gonna you afraid of heights
ah my turn bison bison Bacchae bison
either even no nice distance
who saw that I don't know Oh
ha me flip it bison I say you yeah yeah
that's good hey em where's my drink
all right hold on we have to put someone
we have to silence someone it is we have
- what do you mean sounds there's
someone we just have to silence yeah
that's him the blue jacket on the right
but I won't give up
he's lost yeah
what ok on your horse Jack that drive
around town but he'll die fine
we got a hog time we got to kill him a
more creative way ok let's think - she's
drown him could do that
before I leave will Gavin to bed
[Laughter]
expecting a jump yes not know he's dead
oh I didn't see a red X yep
you killed him I think this sawed-off
shotgun is uh is a nice touch for dirty
Artie's arsenal it's good he's got a
real complete package yeah you've got
tomahawk great for long range skin hat
yeah um uh good for long-range sniping
[Music]
yeah you don't know me good morning yeah
you don't know me
well football coin for the witness
wherever they are perfect heads or tails
leave them alone I guess
oh there's two people in there so skip
for the alone that was for the driver oh
you gotta kill her flip it again yeah
yeah yeah I'll run over oh yeah yeah
Oh drag his ass maybe we take him on the
down the waterfall with us yes
let's bring his corpse with us Oh God
better flip it again kill him always got
shotgun so do you dude that slow
turnaround was so freakin badass dang it
geez oh I must have flipped this wrong
yeah yeah try Oh yep
kill oh it says killer
oh let's write them over we wouldn't
want that we want our man just the way
he's coming for I'm going for my friend
oh [ __ ]
we'll make room I don't know how from
this guy's perspective just pushes the
old dead body I can't be good oh we
almost lost you wouldn't want that now
would we squeezed off the horse not a
word we Malone sugar before I finished
my sentence man this coin really goes in
dirty Artie's favor huh does we can't
even get out of here Oh God all right
just kill are you flipping anything okay
let it will let him live I'm kind of
flipping it like once I'm flipping at
once
oh wait hold on oh oh yeah yeah whoa
we have important business to do Oh
donkey
[Music]
can we put whatever that's our that's
our cargo or Steve to is our cargo or
let's just let's just keep come on Steve
dude no just go it is whistle I'll
follow you go to that going the wrong
way stays Dave stupid oh my god so well
another one kill
[Music]
how about wow we have really racked up
the body count definitely have come on
Steve due out today was that kill I
think I heard quite the convoy we have
here so it's seen this what in the hell
dead
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
perfect throw them offers I don't I
don't think you'll be able to put them
on
I'll look your horse is going I think
can you put them on oh no come on and
fly really good that was really good
I've lied about that all right well
thank you guys so much for watching stay
tuned next week and every week on
Fridays were another chapter of dirty RT
we'll see if we can find a canoe next
time we'll see if we can find a canoe
next time and be more prepared have a
great day everyone
see
[Music]
his mistletoe over the door
you can't heat our drink anymore
the family's crest on the floor drank
too much worth
[Music]
and everyone's having a ball
[Music]
the neighbors have come round to call
if something is missing that's all
there's Christmas time
we all come together today
try to forget yesterday
it's hard to believe again father
[Music]